[Music]
for our daily cancellation we head back
to history class a subject that kids
learn every year in public school which
means that they never really learned the
subject at all of course
it falls then to others sometimes it
even falls to podcasters without a
college degree to pick up the slack
that's what i tried to do over the
weekend and then on my show on monday as
we discussed the issue of slavery no
need to rehash all of my points my
primary goal was to communicate the fact
that the story of slavery is much larger
much deeper much wider ranging than the
version they tell in schools in the
media in hollywood
as i observed white people were slaves
also millions of them were in fact the
trade in white slaves especially in
north africa but even in north america
was big business
it's a fact an important one
but not everybody agreed which isn't to
say that they disagreed with the facts
that i was shown you can't disagree with
facts you can either choose to
acknowledge them or not
but facts don't care about your feelings
or your acknowledgement it turns out no
the critics disagree now with the
indisputable facts about slavery that i
discussed
but rather with the fact that i was
discussing them they felt that it was
horrible nazi-esque uh it was racist
white supremacist to even hint that
there might be more to the slavery issue
than the white enslavement of black
africans in the west from the 17th 19th
centuries
as mentioned on the show on monday the
critics were mostly on the left but not
solely
maj toure who's a well-known gun rights
activist was quite vigorous and
relentless in his criticism he said that
my statements about slavery were dumb
reductive counterproductive horrible
[ __ ] his word and many other things
he said that i was damaging the inroads
that conservatives had made with the
black community
and he continued in this vein in many
tweets and videos railing against me for
mentioning that white people were slaves
so finally on monday he appeared on my
friend jason whitlock show on the blaze
to further explain his point of view
i watched the segment and i have to tell
you that after listening to him if
anything i understand his criticisms
less than i did before so let's go
through this together listen
first um i i did like what is a woman um
i think matt is usually spot on on
certain things it's this is similar to a
lot of um conservatives i'm very
critical
it's almost like if we're going into the
tactic room right
what does this actually prove i just did
an interview um and you know we
discussed a guy said well you know what
would be wrong with all lives matter and
i'm like well there's nothing
technically wrong with it if you thought
that you should have said it before blm
said black lives matter it's just what
it is and everybody knows i don't really
bang with blm as an organization but the
phrase in the redec
redactive you know reductive component
well this is perhaps beside the point
but for the record
lots of us were saying all lives matter
before blm came along
that was and still is the central motto
of the pro-life movement we didn't steal
it from them they stole it from us
we didn't start saying all lives matter
when blm came along we kept saying it
we were told
though that we had to stop saying it
because somehow left-wing black
activists were the only ones allowed to
decide and declare which lives mattered
but but even if we had started saying it
only after blm was formed so what it's
still true
and besides this is meant to be a
response and corrective to blm militants
who in fact as is obvious do not believe
that all lives matter
the blm movement is a black supremacist
movement and that's why all lives matter
was and still is a necessary rejoinder
to it
by the way maj is the founder of an
organization called black guns matter
he sells t-shirts with the phrase on it
so maj were you saying black guns matter
before black lives matter came along
something tells me that you weren't yet
you can use the blm slogan to sell
shirts and advocate for gun rights but
we can't use it to advocate for the
fundamental worth and value of human
life in general
it's reductive for us to say all lives
matter but not for you to say black guns
matter
interesting
let's continue
and let me be clear
if we're trying to make inroads into
black communities these types of takes
that have nothing to do with anything
yeah well i gotta i gotta stop you there
again very briefly we'll back up and
play the whole clip but
uh he says my take had nothing to do
with anything
well that's not true i mean it had
something to do with history uh with
truth with the facts of the world that
shaped human civilization it had
something to do with the racial
grievance industry which trades on the
idea that slavery in america was a
unique and unprecedented evil when in
fact it was not it was an evil but not
unique or unprecedented it had something
to do with lots of different things it
had something to do with a book that i
read and i wanted to talk about it had
something to do with what happened to be
on my mind at that moment all of these
are perfectly fine rationales for
sharing my thoughts
the criticism that maj is offering here
is by far the most useless boring and
exhausting form of criticism and also
perhaps the most common on the internet
that's why i find it so irritating uh
this is the you know why are you talking
about this why talk about this and not
something else i i don't care about this
why are you discussing it it's that
whole routine
it's a totally worthless critique it
really is just because you don't find a
subject important or relevant or worthy
of consideration doesn't mean that
nobody should ever talk about it
i don't have to explain to you why i
want to discuss something
i don't have to seek your permission
ahead of time
if you don't care about the subject or
find it important then keep moving keep
scrolling no one's forcing you to
participate in a conversation that you
apparently find so unworthy of your
attention
it just would never i'd never do this to
people i never go into go to someone
else's page or listen to their podcast
or whatever and then say why are you
talking about this why this and not not
this other thing over
here it's just the the criticism makes
no sense bad school season is uh upon us
and while many american kids are excited
to get back into the classroom
many others are not because these
children they don't know where their
meals will be coming from this semester
that's why goodranchers has made it
their mission to donate 100 000 high
quality meals to kids facing food
insecurity and malnourishment
malnourishment this fall semester for
every box order through the month of
august good ranchers will donate a
nutritious meal to a child in need help
them reach their goal of 100 000 donated
meals by ordering your box today at
goodranchers.com
good ranchers is an award-winning food
delivery service that ships 100 american
meat and seafood right to your door
they're named the best food subscription
service that's what they were named
earlier this year and you could tell why
if you become a subscriber good ranchers
is the fastest growing meat company in
america they source only the best
american farm so you can trust that
you're feeding your family with the
highest possible quality every single
meal plus right now you can use my code
matt to get 30 off your first order plus
free shipping
your purchase further is its mission to
donate 100 000 high quality meals to
children in need this is a great cause
that we should all rally behind go to
goodranchers.com matt today use my code
matt when you place your order and let's
help these guys hit their goal
so we're not off to a good start but
let's continue
these types of takes that have nothing
to do with anything
kinda like just gives extreme leftists
more of a tool to utilize against us and
what i mean by that is
if i'm a person in the middle let's say
i'm a democrat and i'm not the extreme
lefty i think a lot of these guys are
making moves that are in
uh like reactionary to what extreme
lefties do
that doesn't advance conservative
movements
to people that may be in the middle in a
democratic city
so we say a thing and then an extreme
leftist packages and says see they're
minimizing
your ability or the the history of the
transatlantic slave trade now matt may
have not been trying to do that i'm
talking about from a tactical and
strategic standpoint the left dominates
urban and black america because they
understand pr and messaging way better
than the right does simple and plain
they have to because they don't have
many facts sorry they just don't so they
have to be very good at smoking mirrors
and lying in pr because that's what a
lot of public relations or perception
and reality is
this and and i think maybe matt's
following maybe took it a little too
they got a little sensitive about it but
it's always
one step in the right direction with a
lot of conservatives
and then we say something that makes the
job of my job a lot more difficult
because it's like damn that sounds like
you trying to
downplay the role and that's what every
extreme leftist is going to do and so
from a strategic and tactical standpoint
this does not spread conservative values
or make the job better we keep going
with this facts don't care about your
feelings concept and how has that been
working out for us by not expressing any
type of empathy first
uh well it's worked out pretty well
actually thank you for asking refusing
to be emotionally blackmailed by
dishonest manipulative cry bullies has
been a tremendously
successful approach it's one of the
reasons why the guy who coined that
phrase is one of the most influential
thinkers in the country and the company
he co-founded is making inroads into the
culture in ways that nobody else on the
right ever has certainly including our
friend maj but let's back it up a bit
maj accuses me of being reactionary
right reacting to the left
and yet his entire critique centers
around the the left and how he thinks we
should react to it
well we can't say that the radical left
will use it against us
he suggests that the black community
will be easily duped by the dishonest
talking points of the left and so that
we should calibrate our approach
accordingly
he does allow generously that perhaps i
wasn't trying to minimize the
transatlantic slave trade maybe i wasn't
but he says that the left will accuse me
of doing that
so let me see if i have this right
you're worried that the left will accuse
me of something dishonestly and so your
strategy is to head them off at the pass
and accuse me of it first
now maj you're a smart guy i know that
you're not dumb enough to believe that i
was minimizing the slave trade
or indeed that any rational person would
ever do that
suggesting that i even might have tried
to minimize the slave trade by talking
about other forms of slavery it's like
suggesting that i might be minimizing
kidney cancer by talking about lung
cancer
it's an incoherent ridiculous
fundamentally dishonest accusation and
you know it
everybody understands
that slavery in america
was a terrible evil
nobody suggests otherwise
everybody agrees that it was bad which
is all the more reason why perhaps at
this point it might be time to expand
the conversation to talk about the forms
of slavery that lots of people don't
even know existed
we talk about slavery all the time in
america the american form of slavery
kids learn about it
they make movies about it activists
scream about it it is a constant
ever-present historical reality nobody
has forgotten it nobody could ever
forget it
everyone knows that it happened and
everyone agrees that it was unspeakably
evil and it should not have happened
everybody everybody
okay
which is which is good right it's good
that everybody knows it happened and
everyone thinks it's bad
success on that subject
should that be the end of the slavery
conversation or might we at this
juncture
widen the lens a little bit
to try to get a look at the fuller
picture
now it seems that you would prefer
that we keep the lens narrow
and rather than admitting that your
preference is your preference you try to
farm it off to the radical left claiming
that you're only telling me what they
will say
and sure yeah the left does say that any
discussion of historical atrocities not
centered around the plight of black
africans in america is inherently racist
they do say that and they're wrong
you're saying it too and you are also
wrong
now you talk about tactics and strategy
you use the word interchangeably like
they mean the same thing they don't
strategy is your overall approach to the
war tactics are the maneuvers the
individual steps specific actions that
you take and service to that strategy
i'm not splitting hairs here i mean the
difference is actually important because
you say that we should avoid certain
uncomfortable truths strategically and
also tactically but which is it is is
this our strategy is our strategy to
abandon the truth seed the entire
historical and racial narrative to the
left in hopes of outflanking them to
their left
if so then sure i mean only talking
about slavery or racial injustice in
terms of the left demands is a good
tactic
but it's a tactic and a strategy that
loses the war it is a surrender
see my goal my strategy and my tactic
are actually all the same for me
um because i'm a simple man so for me
it's the truth
i just say what is true
if i say something and it's not true
you know if i inadvertently say
something i'm incorrect about what i'm
saying and you have a counter-argument
that proves that it's incorrect then i
will listen
and uh and if you can convince me that
it was incorrect then i'll change my
point of view but if you admit that i'm
saying the truth
and you still criticize me for saying it
well i'm just not interested in that
critique i'm really not
if one person is saying the truth and
the other person doesn't want to hear
the truth whatever their reason
the problem lies entirely 100 with the
latter so you say well what about all
the people who don't want to hear about
this that's their problem
that's not my problem
there is something wrong with them that
they don't want to hear
a truth
and in this case they don't want to hear
a truth about the way the entire world
worked for thousands of years
that's their problem
not mine
as for me you know i think what our
culture lacks most of all is not empathy
it's not feeling it's not pity or
patronizing pat's on the head but truth
and anyone who stands against truth
or insists that the truth be muffled or
silenced or withheld
is today i'm afraid to say
maj
cancel
if you want to join my exclusive fan
base or a cult as really that's what it
is we're joined we're forming a cult
then all you gotta do is click the
subscribe button and ring the bell below
uh this video to stay up to date with
all my content and if you want even more
you can watch or listen to my show at
thedailywire.com spotify or apple
podcast looking forward to welcoming you
to the sweet baby gang